-Now, obviously,
"The President Show,"
which was a show I adored.
-I did too.
-Yeah.
It's sadly not coming back.
Do you miss it?
Do you want a --
Do you want to,
in the moment now --
I could just throw you out
a few press conference questions
and get a little Trump from you?
Would you mind that?
-We could improvise
a little bit, sure.
-How do you feel?
Are you worried today
with the indictment
of Michael Cohen
that this could
lead back to you now?
I mean, he specifically
named you in court.
-No, Michael -- First off,
Individual 1 isn't me, okay?
That's an individual,
and he's one guy.
He's one guy.
We don't know who he is.
And Michael was talking to him.
I don't know who he is.
I'll never know him.
I'll never know Individual 1.
No matter how hard
I stare into the mirror,
I'll never know him.
I'll never really know him.
Melania says she knows him.
What's the next question?
-The next question is --
-Come on. Let's go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Obviously,
I don't need to tell you this,
but Democrats
took back control of the House.
And now, you know --
-Excuse me, excuse me.
They took the House.
We took the Senate.
-Yeah.
-And I told Chuck,
and I told Nancy the other day,
and they were at me
from both sides!
They were spit-roasting me
with questions.
And --
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I would just say,
you know, if I could,
Mr. President,
you say you took the Senate.
You had the Senate.
-I had the Senate,
and I took it back.
[ Laughter ]
-You lost the House.
You had the House.
You lost the House.
-I never really lost the House,
because the House always wins.
[ Laughter ]
And we know that from a casino.
We know it from "Casino,"
the great Joe Pesci.
He gets put in that ditch.
And that's gonna happen
to Don Jr.
if he messes up,
I'll tell you that.
-Can I throw out some names
of some potential
2020 opponents, maybe?
-You can give me
anybody you want.
They're all gonna lose.
And even if I lose, I promise
you, I will not concede.
-Okay.
What about Beto O'Rourke?
A lot of people are talking
about Beto O'Rourke.
-Beto. Beto!
Guy's a Beto male.
He's a total Beto male!
And he's a lanky guy,
and he's big old neck apple.
You know that neck apple?
-Yeah.
-The neck apple.
And Eve took a bite
from the neck apple,
and then
the whole thing was screwed,
so we can't have that guy.
He's a snake.
-Elizabeth War--
Elizabeth Warren?
-Pocahonta-s-s-s-s.
Elizabeth Warren took the bait.
I don't know.
Let me tell you,
I know a good guy named Anthony
from Massachusetts
who would say, "Never let
someone from Massachusetts
run for president, ever.
Doesn't anyone
remember Dukakis?"
Dukakis.
[ Laughter ]
Exactly.
-What about Cory Booker.
-Book 'em, Danno!
Let me tell you
about Cory Booker.
Guy's bald, big bald guy.
And he likes the ladies.
We all know that.
He likes the ladies.
Booker, he's got a big mouth,
and he used to jump over the --
He used to drive a car --
T.J. Booker, tough guy.
T.J. Booker.
And that guy totally resurrected
his career from "Star Trek."
So unbelievable.
-Oh, my God.
It's fantastic.
Fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Both laugh ]
-It's frightening.
-Every now and then,
someone would say to me,
"Hey, would you want to have
the president on this show?"
And the thing I would say is,
it wouldn't matter.
There's this idea that there's
a good interview
out there with him
where he'll actually answer
the questions that are asked.
Would you ever, though,
like to, as him, interview him?
Do you think
that you could maybe --
[ Laughter ]
You know,
I've never thought I --
I guess, on my show,
we had this same question.
And mind you, he was never
gonna come to our show.
-Sure, right.
-But we did have Deepak Chopra.
So, the point being --
[ Laughs ]
The point being, I don't think
the value in interviewing him
is only for
your own benefit, right?
Like, for your own
humor benefit.
You're not gonna
get information from him.
You're not
gonna get anything new.
-Yeah.
-And, to me, you just
serve a platform
for him to peacock more.
And I think that the greatest or
most bizarre thing
is that we're still,
three years in,
trying to calculate
what the pieces
that were missing about him,
especially in the media
and his coverage,
and it's like,
"There is no 'there' there."
I might have said this before
but it's, like,
this is Chauncey Gardiner, like,
times a thousand,
which is from "Being There."
-Put it on with your Steely Dan.
-"Put it on
with your Steely Dan"!
And then get a rotary telephone
and call your grandmother.
But I just don't think
there's any value,
and I think that the thing is,
you know, like a tumor,
which our President
is a tumor on democracy,
we need to cut the oxygen off.
And the way you cut the oxygen
off is stop focusing on him.
-Yeah.
-There's so many
important things --
There's so many things
that are important
that both sides
need to deal with.
And, especially,
I speak to the left, which is,
we need to think about
the issues that aren't as sexy
as sort of like the marquee
things of taking down Trump.
Tort reform, for instance.
I know no one wants
to talk about it,
but people's rights in court
are being taken away
by corporations every day,
and we have Amazon
moving to New York very soon,
and arbitration
is the name of the game
when it comes to trying
to sue a business for money.
These are real things
that affect people, right?
How we employ people,
keeping children in prison.
Those things matter,
and they're not interesting,
and they don't stay
on the bill every day.
And prosecuting the president
over a long-form period
on cable news
isn't gonna do anything.
But we can do things
every day that matter
by changing our behavior
and how we interact
with people in our lives.
That's more important than
interviewing the president.
-Well, couldn't agree more.
And thank you for being here,
buddy.
It is always
just such a pleasure to see you.
-Thank you so much.
-Anthony Atamanuik, everybody.